(musique solennelle)
- C'est l'homme politique
chinois le plus puissant
depuis Mao.ao.
"Ce congrès se déroule, dit-il,
au moment où le parti et la
Chine sont engagés sur la voie
de la construction d'un pays
socialiste moderne."
Un pays où la politique
draconienne de COVID zéro,
de confinement et de contrôle
des citoyens sera maintenue.
Xi Jinping la défend
vigoureusement.
(en mandarin)
Il affirme avoir assuré la santé
des Chinois, tout en protégeant
le développement économique.
La croissance économique est
cependant à son plus bas niveau
en près de 40 ans en Chine,
ce qui fait de la stratégie
sanitaire chinoise un pari
risqué selon cette analyste.
VALÉRIE NIQUET, auteure
"La Chine en 100 questions"
- Si l'économie n'allait pas
mieux, si les découragements
de la population augmentaient,
si jamais il y avait une reprise
du COVID, tout ça, sont des
risques qui pèsent sur l'avenir
du système politique en Chine.
- Xi Jinping fustige
par ailleurs les provocations
extérieures et ce qu'il qualifie
d'ingérence étrangère à Taïwan.
rêve d'annexer
pacifiquement l'île qu'elle
considère être son territoire.
Mais le président chinois répète
qu'il n'exclut pas l'usage
de la force.
(en mandarin)
"Seul le peuple chinois doitrésn
de Taïwan," lance-t-il.
Dans une déclaration écrite,
le gouvernement taïwanais répond
que l'île est un État souverain.
ANTOINE BONDAZ, chargé de rech.,
Programme Taïwan sécurité, dipl.
- C'est d'effacer l'expérience
que représente aujourd'hui
Taïwan. C'est-à-dire une société
chinoise, en tous cas de culture
chinoise, multi-ethnique, qui a
connu une dictature extrêmement
brutale, mais qui s'est
démocratisée de l'intérieur.
- De quoi surprendre certains
analystes; Xi Jinping ne fait
aucune mention de l'Ukraine
ou de la Russie dans sonns sonnn
discours de près de deux heures.
(applaudissements)
rmation du troisième
mandat historique de Xi Jinping
ainsi que la composition du
bureau politique du Parti
communiste chinois devraient
noncées le lendemain
de la conclusion du congrès,
la semaine prochaine.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Tai